- I'm Paul North.
I teach in the German Department at Yale.
This is a series
at the Whitney Humanities Center
called "The Value of Marx's Capital."
These are the Franke
Lectures in the Humanities
at the Whitney Humanities Center.
I need to do some thank yous.
First of all, the Franke
Lectures are made possible
by the generosity of
Richard and Barbara Franke
and are intended to
present important topics
in the humanities to a
wide and general audience.
I'd like to thank Alice Kaplan,
the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center
for making possible what seemed
to have been potentially
impossible this year.
So thank you, Alice.
To Sandra Malan Bowles and
Leana Hirschfeld-Kroen
for doing the organization,
and to Audrey Leak our intrepid,
brilliant undergraduate
tech assistant, thank you.
The workshop is gonna run like this.
We'll have a presentation
from our speaker,
and then we'll do questions.
I'm gonna ask you to hold
your questions if you can
until after the speaker speaks
and then to put them in the chat.
We'll then go through the
chat and open up your mics
when it's time for you
to read your question.
If you put in questions earlier,
they're likely to get lost.
I like to start with a quote
from a text from the speaker.
So I want to start from with
a quote from our speaker
from the "Boston Review"
in February of 2018,
quote, "Asking what the
slave trade says about Marx
"requires that we start where Marx did,
"with analysis of the commodity form.
"But we need to replace
the bolt of linen Marx used
"as the iconic object of that analysis.
"Not with slave-cultivated cotton
"that was more central
"to 19th century industrial manufacturing
"or even the slave-grown sugar
"that fueled the colonial wealth,
"Marx erroneously identified
"as part of capitalism's prehistory.
"To heed Johnson's call to quote,
"'Use the history of slaves as the source
"'rather than the subject
of knowledge,' unquote
"we will have to instead put
the enslaved human herself
"at the center of our analysis
of the commodity form."
When I read the sentence,
I was really galvanized
and invited Stephanie
Smallwood to join us.
We're really grateful that you're here.
Stephanie Smallwood is
associate professor of history
and comparative history of ideas
at the University of Washington, Seattle,
where she's also a faculty associate
of the Harry Bridges
Center for Labor Studies.
Her research and teaching
explore early modern histories
of slavery, colonialism, and race
with particular emphasis on
the transatlantic slave trade,
racial capitalism and African
diasporas in the Americas.
As far as I can see,
she's the most interesting
political economist
of slavery going.
She's the author of "Saltwater Slavery:
"A Middle Passage from
Africa to American Diaspora"
from 2007, which won the
2008 Frederick Douglass prize
from Yale's own Gilder Lehrman Center.
She's at work on a project
called "Africa in the Atlantic World:
"A Geopolitical History."
And we're really happy
to have you and welcome.
- Thank you so much.
It's an honor to be here,
an honor to spend the evening
discussing the value of capital.
And I'll just say that I am relieved,
not quite fully relieved,
but happy to be starting this conversation
knowing that that thing that
we're all watching obsessively
has started to inch in
the right direction.
So I can kind of leave my
obsession with the election
and focus on what we're here for today.
Thank you, Paul, for that quote.
It is a perfect segue, I think,
into what I want to do today.
I wanna start by saying a little bit
about how I've come to
develop a deep interest
in the Marxian account of capital.
It's not an obvious set
of interests for me,
since I'm actually not a specialist
in political theory or political economy,
but as a historian of slavery
and of the transatlantic slave trade
and one whose research
has focused particularly
on how the early modern
Atlantic system organized itself
around the production and circulation
of people as commodities,
I guess it became inevitable
that eventually I would
have to engage with Marx.
So off and on over the years
since I published "Saltwater Slavery,"
I've dabbled in the
debates on the relationship
of capitalism to slavery.
And I've done so always a bit confused
and bemused by the ways
those debates rarely extend
beyond questions about 19th
century antebellum slavery
in the U.S.
The question that follows
me around relentlessly
whenever I'm deep into Marx's oeuvre
concerns the relationship of capitalism
to the transatlantic world of slavery
in the 16th, 17th, and 18th centuries.
So my questions have less
to do with the entanglements
of British abolitionism, cotton
slavery in the U.S. South
and the rise of industrial
capitalism in the 19th century
and more to do with how to
make sense of the long history
of what Marx called the capitalist era,
beginning in the 16th century.
So with the thoughts I'm
going share this afternoon
or this evening for you all,
I want to problematize a central assertion
of Marx's account of capital,
and that's namely his insistence
that the circumstances in which
money could be transformed
into capital were limited
to the time and place
of 19th century industrialization
in Northern Europe.
And I want to suggest
that the histories of
transatlantic circulation
and enslavement of African people must be
at the center of any adequate
account of capitalism.
And in doing so, I'm gonna propose
that we need to rethink
the Marxian account
of New World slavery
as capital, so-called
primitive accumulation.
A useful place to begin,
I think, is to remind
ourselves why Marx insisted
on framing the conditions of possibility
for the capital relation to
emerge as narrowly as he did.
And on that point, I want us to remember
that the revolution he was trying
to eliminate was not the
production of surplus value itself.
That's not what was
special about capitalism.
More precisely, it was the
money owner's discovery
that he can generate
surplus value in perpetuity
by the appropriation of a
particular form of labor,
which of course, as we know,
from our reading of "Capital"
was the specific form of free labor.
So I'm gonna go ahead and share my screen
and pull up the first slide.
Marx elaborated the conditions
that made labor free, very precisely.
What the capital relation required,
according to him, was
labor power's presence
in the market as a commodity.
And we can use this passage
from his discussion of the sale
and purchase of labor power,
one of several very
explicit statements on this,
to recall Marx's precise words
regarding the four conditions
that labor's appearance
in the market as a commodity required.
Number one, it had to
be sold as a commodity
by its possessor.
And so we get Marx telling us
that labor power can appear
on the market as a commodity only if,
and in so far as its possessor,
the individual whose labor power it is,
offers it for sale or
sells it as a commodity.
Second, he tells us that the possessor
of labor power has to have full ownership
of his labor power.
He must possess himself.
And so Marx writes,
"The possessor must
have it at his disposal.
"He must be the free proprietor
"of his own labor capacity,
hence of his person."
Third, the two parties
to this transaction,
the owner of money and
the owner of labor power,
must be equals, juridically at least.
And so Marx insists
that both have to be equal
in the eyes of the law.
And lastly, the system's
infinite momentum, right?
That essential feature
that is capital's ability
to reproduce valorization
in perpetuity requires
that the possessor of
labor power be compelled
to return to the market
over and over again.
And so it is necessary that
he sell his labor power
only for a delimited period of time.
And on this, Marx writes,
"For this relation to continue,
"the proprietor of labor
power must always sell it
"for a limited period only."
Why?
Because if he were to sell the
totality of his labor power
all at once,
he would effectively make
himself into an enslaved person.
And so Marx concludes this passage saying,
"For if he were to sell it
in a lump, once and for all,
"he would be selling himself,
"converting himself from
a free man into a slave,
"from an owner of a
commodity into a commodity."
And so with this, we have
Marx's central axiom,
that capital's endless
self-valorization requires
not just the labor power,
that labor power itself
become a commodity,
but more precisely, that it
appear repeatedly in the market.
And further, that this can only occur
when labor power is brought to
the market by the free person
in whom it is embedded,
what he referred to as alienation by sale.
So the African enslaved worker does not
and indeed cannot appear
as a central protagonist
in Marx's account of capital.
For Marx, if the laborer
in question is enslaved,
a fully-commoditized person,
we can no longer be in the
terrain of the capital relation.
If the circulation of labor power,
freely alienated by sale
is the necessary condition of possibility
for the emergence of the capital relation,
what I want to ask is the
place of Atlantic slavery
and its circulation of labor
power alienated by coercion
and capital's story?
As someone who studies the
commoditization of people,
the full commoditization of people,
and the circulation of commoditized
people for their labor,
this is what I want to
keep open as a question.
I want to ask whether
slavery as capitalism
is as unthinkable as Marx insisted.
And what I'll try to do
today is persuade you
that enslaved Africans can
and should be at the center
of our account of modern capital.
So I'm gonna organize my
thoughts for this evening
around two questions.
Number one, what did Marx
think he knew about slavery,
and number two, what did Marx
need to know about slavery
but failed to ask?
So the first question,
what did Marx think he knew about slavery?
And my slides for some
reason are not advancing.
Can you guys help me with this?
I can't get these slides
to advance for some reason.
- I wonder if maybe you should unshare,
just restart the program and share again.
That's the extent of my
technical help I can give.
- Let's try this again.
They were working when we tested it.
- We're gonna get them
working again, I'm sure of it.
- It's still not working.
What happens if I do it,
I'm gonna try it one more
time a different way,
which is to do my desktop
instead of the app.
- [Paul] Okay.
- Still not working. That's so odd.
- Okay, let's pause for a minute.
Audrey or Guy, do you have any advice?
We can also, if you use send it to-
- You guys have it. I did send it.
- [Leana] I have the PowerPoint.
Audrey has the PowerPoint.
One of us can Screen
Share instead, absolutely.
- Yeah, let's do it that way.
- Audrey, do you wanna do that for us?
- [Audrey] Yes.
- Thank you.
- Let's see.
Can you move them, Audrey?
Do they go?
Okay.
How does that seem?
- Is that okay?
- Stephanie, are you seeing it?
- I'm not, although maybe-
- On your Zoom, we have it or I have it.
I think we're onto the second slide.
This relation has no
basis in natural history.
- Oh, there it is.
Is that it? No, that's.
- Well, we're seeing it.
So I guess if you ask Audrey-
- Okay, now I'm seeing it.
Yep, I got it.
- Okay.
- And that's the one that I deleted.
So the next slide.
Yes, there we go.
Perfect, thank you so much.
Okay.
So what did Marx think
he knew about slavery?
Well before he had begun the research
at the British Museum that
would become "Capital,"
Marx had already identified slavery
as an important part
of the story of 19th
century industrialization.
In his 1847 "Poverty of Philosophy,"
he famously wrote that direct slavery
is just as much the pivot
of bourgeois industry
as machinery, credits, et cetera.
Without slavery, you have no cotton.
Without cotton, you
have no modern industry.
It is slavery that has given
the colonies their value.
It is the colonies that
have created world trade,
and it is world trade
that is the precondition
of large-scale industry.
"Thus," he writes, "slavery
is an economic category
"of the greatest importance."
Marx knew the value slavery
gave to the New World colonies,
because he was reading the
current historical literature
on English colonizing,
works by Herman Merivale,
for example, that explained
which colonies were producing commodities
for the international market
and which ones weren't
and told him of Jamaica's
status, for instance,
as the greatest sugar-growing
country in the world.
That is to say Marx knew
the aggregate measure
of the wealth returned to Europe
by the importation and consumption
of colonial commodities.
And it was in this
idiom that he understood
the value slavery gave to the colonies.
And it's in this sense
also that Marx assigned
to New World slavery the role
of contributing substantially
to capital's era of
primitive accumulation,
the amassing of capital and labor power
that had taken place
outside the cyclical movement of capital.
The historical break,
we might say, or shift
that as Marx put it was
quote, "Not the result
"of the capitalist mode of production,
"but rather its point of departure."
What Marx characterized
as the treasures captured outside Europe
by undisguised looting,
enslavement and murder
that flowed back to the mother country
and were turned into capital there.
Next slide, please.
And so in this sharply worded
and often quoted statement,
we get Marx's most explicit observation
regarding the multiple
and global appropriations
he's characterized
as capital's prehistory
of primitive accumulation.
He writes that the discovery
of gold and silver in America,
the extirpation, enslavement
and entombment in mines
of the indigenous population
of that continent,
the beginnings of the
conquest and plunder of India
and the conversion of
Africa into a preserve
for the commercial hunting of black skins
are all things which characterize the dawn
of the era of capitalist production.
"These idyllic proceedings,"
he says ironically,
"are the chief moments of
primitive accumulation."
But if it wasn't as an economic category
that the particular historical instance
of New World slavery was an important part
of capital's story, what, I want to ask,
about slavery as a category of labor?
we should notice in this passage
that Marx has invoked European
slave trading in Africa,
the commercial hunting of black skins,
but he has not explicitly
named the New World plantation
and its expropriation of African labor.
Instead here, it is the mineral wealth
and the expropriation of indigenous labor
that occupies his interest in slavery
as a mode of production
in the colonized Americas.
For a 19th Century European
political economy general,
generally speaking, slavery was a static
and unchanging mode of production.
And as such, it was understood
to have certain universal characteristics.
As a system of labor exploitation,
slavery was understood to claim
the spoils of surplus labor,
the same as any system
that concentrated ownership
of the means of production
in the hands of a dominant social class.
But, and this is significant,
conventional wisdom had it that slavery
would not turn surplus labor
into surplus value or profit.
Because slave labor power was part
of the means of production,
it would not be subjected
to the scale of exploitation
and abuse associated
with the drive to profit
from labor surplus.
The expectation then was that
owners would not be inclined
to direct slave labor power
toward production from market exchange.
And so slavery was
expected to limit itself
to the production of use values
but not approach the
production of exchange values.
Next slide, please.
Marx explained it this way.
He wrote, "It is clear that
in any economic formation
"of society, where they use value
"rather than the exchange value
"of the product predominates,
"surplus labor will be restricted
"by a more or less confined set of needs.
"And that no boundless thirst
for surplus labor will arise
"from the character of production itself.
"Hence in antiquity
overwork becomes frightful
"only when the aim is
to obtain exchange value
"in its independent monetary shape,
"i.e. in the production
of gold and silver.
"The recognized form of overwork here
"is forced labor until death.
"Nevertheless, these are
exceptions in antiquity."
So there were exceptions
specifically in the context
of the production of mineral wealth,
but the normative rule, so it was thought,
was that slavery used labor
power without despoiling it.
And in this crucial sense,
it did not approach the abuses typical
of 19th century industrial wage labor.
For instance, when
describing how the value
of labor power is determined
by the social costs of its production,
Marx drew on the example
of ancient Roman slavery
to illustrate the point,
explaining that the
overseers in ancient Rome
received less food
than the agricultural
slaves they supervised,
because they expended less
labor than the enslaved workers.
And so in this sense,
19th century European political
economy understood slavery
as a patriarchal and
benign mode of production
that was inimical to the
features unique to capital,
its drive, as Marx called
it, to produce exchange value
and the economies of scale
by which its circuits
of valorization renewed
themselves in limitless fashion,
as he put it.
This at least was the body
of theoretical assumptions Marx inherited
in 19th century economic thought.
So what did Marx need
to know about slavery
but failed to ask?
It was by exceeding the
limits it was supposed to have
that slavery became an economic category
so important to capital's story.
The system of slavery made
by European interventions
in Africa and the Americas was a novel
and unprecedented one.
And it shared with European
industrial wage labor
elements Marx revealed as central
to the workings of capital.
It produced surplus value by
making labor power available
in the market in virtually limitless form.
And it did so by the
bureaucratic management
of market circulations.
Marx needed to devote
sustained analytical attention
to the bureaucratically
managed market circulations
that roped Africa
into Europe's transatlantic
commercial network
and pulled enslaved African labor power
into the net of European
colonizing in the Americas.
And he needed to reconcile
his inherited abstractions
about slavery as a mode of production
with the actual material history
of slavery in the New World.
To do that, he needed to ask how exactly
did slavery give the colonies their value?
He needed to ask more precisely,
how did the labor power
of enslaved Africans
give the colonies so much value?
A full account of modern
capitalism needs to be able
to explain slavery's transformation
under European colonization
in the Americas.
But these questions
were already foreclosed
by Marx's ahistorical
understandings of slavery
and the limited scale of his imagination
with regard to the
conditions of possibility
for the capital relation to emerge.
The result was the awkward
and erroneous grafting
of an anachronistic theory of slavery
onto an historical
reality whose full scope
and operative logics Marx
failed to fully grasp.
Next slide, please.
So we get statements like this one
that produced the provocative
and often quoted pedestal metaphor
by making American
slavery the benign system
that 19th century
economic thought imagined
all slavery systems to be,
until transformed by 19th
century industrialization.
Only then when the cotton industry emerged
was American slavery, so it was thought,
transformed into something akin
to the capital relation itself.
And so Marx writes,
"While the cotton industry
"introduced child slavery into England,
"in the United States,
"it gave the impulse
for the transformation
"of the earlier, more or
less patriarchal slavery
"into a system of commercial exploitation.
"In fact, the veiled
slavery of the wage laborers
"in Europe needed the unqualified slavery
"of the New World as its pedestal."
Next slide, please.
And we get this passage
that continues the line of discussion
we looked at a few minutes ago,
regarding slavery's general orientation
toward production of use values
with no boundless thirst
for surplus labor,
according to 19th century economic theory.
Marx continues the thought as follows:
As soon as peoples whose
production still moves
within the lower forms of slave labor,
the courvee, et cetera, are
drawn into a world market
dominated by the capitalist
mode of production,
whereby the sale of
their products for export
develops into their principal interest,
the civilized horrors
of overwork are grafted
onto the barbaric horrors of
slavery, serfdom, et cetera.
Hence the negro labor
in the southern states
of the American Union preserved
a moderately patriarchal character,
as long as production was chiefly directed
to the satisfaction of
immediate local requirements.
But in proportion, as the export of cotton
became a vital interest to those states,
the overworking of the negro
and sometimes the consumption of his life
in seven years of labor became a factor
and a calculated and calculating system.
It was no longer a question
of obtaining from him a certain
quantity of useful products
but rather of the production
of surplus value itself.
So Marx recognized an affinity
between capitalism and slavery.
The one was the pedestal for the other.
But his only recourse to
explain the relationship
was the egregiously erroneous notion
that there was nothing interesting to know
or observe about the
American slave labor system
until it came under the dark
cloud of European demand
for slave-grown cotton.
Only then did it become, in his view,
a calculated and calculating system.
We have to wonder,
as he conducted the research
that became "Capital,"
sitting in the famed Reading
Room of the British Museum,
a monument to British colonialism founded
by 18th century naturalist
and plantation physician Hans Sloane,
did Marx imagine that
enslaved people ate better
than their overseers across
nearly two centuries,
producing tobacco and rice and indigo
in the plantation societies
of English North America,
the same as they purportedly did
in what he understood as
the benign slave system
of ancient Rome?
Next slide, please.
There's one crucial passage in "Capital"
where Marx comes closest
to getting it right.
And it is this very long passage
where drawing on contemporary economist
J.E. Cairnes' book "The Slave Power,"
Marx comes closest to a full elaboration
of slavery's transformation
under racial capitalism and colonialism.
"The slave owner buys
his worker," he writes,
"in the same way as he buys his horse.
"If he loses his slave, he
loses a piece of capital,
"which he must replace
by fresh expenditure
"on the slave market.
"But take note of this," and
now he is quoting Cairnes:
The rice grounds of Georgia
or the swamps of the Mississippi
may be fatally injurious
to the human constitution,
but the waste of human life
which the cultivation of
these districts necessitates
is not so great that it cannot be repaired
from the teeming preserves
of Virginia and Kentucky.
Considerations of economy, moreover,
which under a natural
system afford some security
for humane treatment by identifying
in the master's interest
with the slave's preservation
when once trading in slaves is practiced
becomes reasons for
racking to the uttermost
the toil of the slave.
For when his place can at once supplied
from foreign preserves,
the duration of his life
becomes a matter of less moment
than its productiveness while it lasts.
Next slide.
It is accordingly a maxim slave management
in slave-importing countries
that the most effective
economy is that which takes out
of human chattel in the
shortest space of time
the utmost amount of
exertion it is capable
of putting forth.
It is in the tropical culture,
where annual profits often
equal the whole capital
of plantations that negro life
is most recklessly sacrificed.
It is the agriculture of the West Indies,
which has been for centuries
prolific of fabulous wealth
that has engulfed millions
of the African race.
It is in Cuba at this day,
whose revenues are reckoned
by millions and whose planters are princes
that we see in the servile
class the coursest fare,
the most exhausting and unremitting toil,
and even the absolute destruction
of a portion of its numbers every year.
And now Marx quotes the Roman poet Horace,
"The name is changed, but
the tale is told of you,"
and concludes, "For the slave trade,
"read or substitute labor market,
"for Kentucky and Virginia
substitute Ireland
"and the agricultural
districts of England,
"Scotland and Wales, for
Africa substitute Germany."
What's missing here,
though it's right there beneath
Marx's eyes is theorization
of the slave trade
itself as a labor market.
It is not just analogous to
the European labor market
but rather the original instantiation
of a particular kind of labor market,
one that produced and circulated
commodified labor power
in the pursuit of surplus value
and did so on a limitless scale.
Marx's invocation of a historical process
that drew slavery into a world market
should have been a reference
to the transatlantic slave trade
and the system of plantation
slavery it sustained
across the colonized
Americas, but it wasn't.
His account of New World
slavery as organized
around production of use values
and thus preserving a moderately
patriarchal character,
as he put it, until it was transformed
by the distorting influence of capital
in the 19th century is more
than a harmless anachronism.
In other words, he doesn't
just get the chronology wrong.
He's unable to fully perceive the nature
of the relationship of
slavery to capitalism.
He credited New World slavery
with being an important economic category,
but absent theorization of
slavery's transformation
under European colonialism,
he failed to perceive the
new labor form it innovated.
So Marx ended up stuck without
a theoretical foundation
for organizing what he knew to
be true of New World slavery,
that it was organized
to produce surplus value
and did so on an economy
of scale never before seen
in world history.
This made it not just an
important economic category
but, moreover, a mode of production
that begged for theorization
on the same terms
as those he deployed to
understand wage labor
and to elaborate the formula
for capital's production of surplus value.
For lack of an ability to
theorize this transformation
of slavery under European
colonizing in the Americas,
Marx cannot but misapprehend
what was its most important feature
with regard to the formula for capital.
By erasing the long history
of colonial chattel slavery
and the transatlantic
slave trade that fueled it,
Marx failed to account
for its economy of scale
and how it achieved that scale,
by the ongoing appearance of
African commodified labor power
in the marketplace.
The African captive
purchased by representatives
of the European state on the African coast
and sold to European planter settlers
in the plantation colonies in the Americas
was the primordial figure
of the worker whose
labor power was subjected
to the violences of
capital's boundless thirst
and voracious appetite for surplus labor.
By the terms then of his
own theorization of capital,
American slavery was
organized around an iteration
of the capital relation
from its beginnings.
Next slide, please
Marx could not empirically know free labor
to be the singular labor form able
to sustain the capital
relation's social reproduction
and satisfy its hunger
for self-valorization,
because he did not closely examine
what proceeded that innovation,
labor power's continual
replacement in the market
by the always reliable reappearance
on the Atlantic horizon
of the transatlantic slave ship.
Colonial slavery
represents a transformation
antecedent to and no
less revolutionary than
the industrial system's appropriation
of free wage labor.
We might call this system
colonial slave capitalism.
Its circulations began with
money expended in Europe
to buy commodities to exchange for people
on the African coast,
and value was mediated
by a transatlantic series
of commodity conversions,
European commodities
exchanged for captive people
on the African coast,
people converted to
commodified labor power
in the transatlantic slave ships,
consumed in the cultivation
of cash crops in the
American plantation systems.
And finally, the circulation closed
with money's final return
back to its initial point of departure
in valorized form by the sale of the sugar
or tobacco or rice or indigo made
by the alienation of slave
labor power by coercion
with all that that entailed, a violence
and indifference toward the
life of the enslaved worker.
The economic form created
by the circulation
of African people as
commodities was money,
and moreover, capital in the Marxian sense
of being money whose value was enlarged
by the expropriation of their labor power.
In other words, the
transatlantic circulation
of Africans followed
capital's general formula.
It put money into circulation
to produce surplus value
that in turn produced more money.
There is no more
straightforward expression
of what Marx called quote,
"the valorization of value"
than what a Jamaican planter
named Cary Helyar said
of the enslaved Africans he purchased
with money advanced by
his brother in England.
After acquiring 14 enslaved Africans
out of a Dutch ship in 1642,
he wrote to his brother promising
that by their labor and the
profits that would ensue,
he would quote, "Make
these negroes buy more."
The 18th century British promoter
of slavery Malachi Postlethwaite opined
that the Africa trade was an
inexhaustible fund of wealth
for the state, but it was more than that.
The system it fueled was
the original laboratory
in which the owners of
money first realized
and innovated the
production of surplus value
by labor power's ongoing
alienation in the marketplace.
That's what Cary Helyar understood.
And it's what Marx evaded
in his account of capital.
So moving now toward a close,
what I've tried to show here today
is that the colonial Atlantic slave system
was a self-perpetuating one,
a system of surplus value production
driven by commoditization of
labor power in the marketplace.
It innovated this by what
I'm calling the alienation
of labor by coercion
and did so prior to
the European innovation
of what Marx called the
alienation of labor power by sale.
And my point is not to flatten
or dissolve the distinction
between these two forms.
What I am insisting on though
is that characterizing
the colonial slave system
as one whose principle role was
as an aggregate accumulation
of wealth that was primitive
in the sense of being outside of
and external to
capitalism's time and place
in 19th century Northern Europe,
Marx's primitive accumulation obscures
more than it reveals.
By attributing to colonial slavery only
the aggregate accumulation
of startup capital,
the primitive accumulation concept masks
and leaves uninvestigated and untheorized
the ways colonial slavery
produced that wealth
by an innovation in the
expropriation of labor power.
It erases colonial slavery's scale.
It distorts its chronology,
and it occludes the
bureaucratic rationalization
of expropriation by violence
developed across three centuries
prior to American slavery's
turn to cotton production.
To invoke Lisa Lowe's analysis
of what she calls the
intimacies of four continents,
a formulation that is so helpful
for seeing relations otherwise obscured
by liberal economic and political thought,
it obscures the ways the managed violences
of colonial capitalist slavery
across three centuries were
not external to Europe at all.
How much enslaved or
indentured labor power,
for instance, did Marx himself consume
in the sugar that sweetened
the tea he surely drank
as he sat in the British
Museum Reading Room
developing his critique
of political economy?
As Lisa Lowe explains by
way of a brilliant reading
of the novel "Vanity Fair,"
"Thackeray's distillation
"of early Victorian
British society revealed
"what Marx's account of capital
did not, the intimacies,"
and I'm quoting here,
"between colonial commodities
"in early Victorian households
and the imperial relations
"to Africa, Asia, and the Americas
"to which they were
inextricably tied," end quote.
"Marx's account," according to Lowe,
"simultaneously recognized
"and ingeniously suppressed the histories
"and geographies of
production that brought sugar,
"tea, silks, and so forth
to British consumers."
And so if a central event
of primitive accumulation
and its hastening of
the shift from feudalism
to capitalism was the transformation
of the slave mode of production,
such that it could exceed the limits
that traditionally inhered in the use
of slave labor power, it
changes our understanding
of the relationship between the two
in important and profound ways.
It suggests that by
understanding American slavery
as the pedestal on which
European wage slavery stood,
if we want to keep Marx's
pedestal and veil metaphor,
we are not just naming slave-grown cotton
as the fuel that fed the system
of wage slavery in Europe,
but moreover, we're naming as primordial
the three centuries of
bureaucratically-managed production
of surplus value through
expropriation of labor power
in the Americas.
We are thus producing better understanding
of why slavery and capitalism
share so many features,
why slave labor and wage
labor are not as distinct
as liberal economic theory
would have us believe.
We are unmasking the otherwise
occluded transformation
of the slave mode of production
under European colonialism.
And we're better understanding the nature
of the pedestal of colonial slavery.
Both colonial slavery
and 19th century industrial production
achieved economies of scale
and limitless capacity
from money's perpetual self-valorization
by the managed bureaucracy
of labor's alienation in the market.
We must not collapse the distinction
between the alienation
of labor by coercion
and its alienation by sale.
But in so far as the
one proceeded the other
and represents a primordial
innovation realized
by slavery's transformation
under colonialism,
we can usefully rethink
the way we periodize
and organize our understanding
of capital's long chronology.
It's in this sense that I insist
that colonial slavery must be understood
as more central even than Marx recognized
with his provocative metaphors
that name the proximity
of slavery to capitalism
without adequately grasping the
nature of that relationship.
And in this sense, to remind us
of the genealogy of
black radical thinkers,
including W. E. B. Du Bois, C. L. R. James
and Eric Williams
who've made the same
point in various ways,
I'm especially indebted to
the sociologist Oliver Cox
who suggested in his 1964
work "Capitalism as a System"
that quote, "Marx begins
his analysis of the nature
"of capitalism almost where
he might have ended it.
"And as is commonly the
case in classical economics,
"he relegates as
subsidiary the very things
"which should have been
the center of his study.
"His primitive accumulation is none other
"than fundamentally capitalist
accumulation," end quote.
Across three centuries,
capital realized the means
to satisfy its hunger for valorization
by the consumption of some
12 and a half million souls,
Well before it shifted to the scene
elaborated so painstakingly by Marx,
the labor market where
the wage worker appears
under the ruse that is bourgeois freedom,
but is, in fact, the end
line of his own enslavement.
If we can understand capital's alienation
of the wage worker's
extensively free labor power
as further innovation of the
proceeding three centuries
of alienation by direct coercion,
as much as being a revolutionary
break with that past,
we have the means to better
understand the intimacies
of slavery and capitalism
and the importance of
slavery's transformation
under racial settler colonialism,
not just to modern capitalism's
conditions of possibility
but also to its core
technologies of violences,
both material and social,
that shape our worlds to this day.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
This is where there would
be thunderous applause,
and we just are imagining it this moment.
Thank you for a great and
eye-opening presentation.
We're going to open
the floor to questions,
and I'm gonna ask folks to put
their questions in the chat.
I especially invite students
from the seminar to pose questions.
Maybe I'll start with one, if
that's okay, if you're ready.
- [Dr. Smallwood] Yeah, yeah.
- So, you know,
I find it totally convincing
and I wonder what other
steps we could take
in thinking about this system,
the system before the system,
the first system, the
model prototype system,
and so one thing that happens
in the wage labor system
that Marx spends a long time
talking about in "Capital"
is the pressure to increase productivity
and to expand the system.
And some of that has to do
with encountering limits
to the number of wage
laborers that you can get.
But there seems to be a kind
of motor of growth in it.
And I wonder if you see anything like that
in the slave capital
system that proceeded it
that you've been describing,
growth, how technology fits,
is there any pressure
to make the slave trade obsolete,
to diminish it in those ways
to help the growth of surplus value,
or is growth not that big of a factor?
- Oh, I would say growth is a huge factor.
And I think, you know, part
of what I think happens is
that we tend to view these
things teleologically.
So, you know, again, of course,
wage labor under industrialization
innovates something even further.
But if we're looking at the
slave system on its own terms
instead of looking at it, you
know, already comparing it
to what is going to happen
a hundred years later,
it's an inefficient system compared
to what's gonna develop,
but it's a system
in which people are
desperately trying to innovate.
And so, you know, some of the studies,
for instance, of plantation
slavery in the sugar colonies
in the Caribbean has shown
that there's an increase
in productivity that
can only be explained by
the further ramping up of slave labor.
And I think part of what
I'm trying to do here
and one of the other things
I think we struggle with is,
the only measure we have in many ways
of the immensity of that system
is the quantitative history,
you know, the numbers.
And it's just so easy to
let 12 and a half million
become an abstraction.
It's so hard for us to really visualize
how much that is the social
reproduction of slavery.
This maxim of using the slave labor up,
knowing that you can replace them,
that it is more efficient.
So again, this idea
that slavery can't work,
it shouldn't work, but it did.
And so that's, I think,
what we have to reckon with
is just how much they were able
and willing to make it work
and that they did so
through a bureaucratic
means of management.
I think part of what Marx
is always trying to do
is to make this primitive accumulation,
because it's happening,
you know, extrajudicially
and outside the state and
it's this kind of domain
of the wild and the piratical,
and no, it's the state.
And the archive, the colonial archive,
the colonial state archive
that documents it is going to make its way
to the British Library.
If he were researching capital,
probably would've needed
to be maybe 50 years later.
Instead of pouring over the Blue Books
he could have poured over
the Royal African Company's papers.
- Thanks, yes.
That would have changed a lot.
One hopes, and okay.
I'm not seeing questions
in the chat so much.
So if you want to raise some
issues or make some comments,
please feel free to do it.
I can, of course, keep asking.
- (laughs) I'm looking at some
of the comments.
I think what happens
sometimes with such an opening
of a whole new world is that
you can't ask the usual,
you know, Marx people like to debate
the finest technical points.
Very rarely interesting,
but this is a whole new issue
from the Marx side obviously.
- Question, "Could you say a little more
"about the role of
bureaucratic management?
"It sounds like, as a way
that the state managed slavery
"as labor, it is maybe
parallel or a precursor
"to the juridical equality
"that, as you point out, Marx emphasized."
I'm not sure what more
to say, but I guess,
I'll just say that what I'm
trying to emphasize, again,
is that it seems to me part
of what Marx wants to do
is to imagine the slave system
and the violences of colonialism generally
as not really being the arm of the state.
Especially in the early modern period.
And so I think that part
of what struck me even
as a researcher when I started
studying the slave trade,
again, was just to realize
just how bureaucratic
and rationalized it was.
And I think when we try to make sense
of certain kinds of violence as, again,
being outside the domain
of the bureaucratic state,
this kind of wild space
that's not managed,
I think that's a way that
we try to rationalize it.
And I think what we have
to reckon with, again,
is the kinds of violence that
the state was quite happy
and dependent upon managing
in a very rationalizing way.
- We have another question
from Sara-Maria Sorentino.
Maybe we'll open up Sara-Maria's mic,
and they can ask the question themselves.
- Hi.
- Thanks for the talk.
I was wondering if you
could say a little bit more
about how it would be possible
to understand or think
slavery on its own terms.
Like, do you think that
there are particular ways
in which we understand the critique
of political economy and
understand capitalism?
Is it totality and understand
materialism is a kind of form
of metaphysics that might preclude us
from understanding
slavery on its own terms?
Like what kind of conceptual
and political tools might we need
in order to begin that endeavor?
- I guess I don't have a
really deeply formulated answer
to that question.
I mean, I think,
and I'm being told that my
internet connection is unstable.
Can you guys hear me?
- We're getting you pretty clearly, yep.
- I think the way to see it
on its own terms is simply to,
to just, you know, use the
archival material that we have
and be critically reflective
such that we're not
projecting teleologically
other formations onto the slave system.
I don't know if that makes sense,
but I don't have a
really sophisticated way
to say what I mean by that, I don't think.
- Yeah, I mean,
this is something that
I study and research.
And so if part of like our
understanding of ideology
or the way that capitalism
impacts our consciousness
is to make it so that
we see certain versions
of freedom as the freedom
that we need to pursue,
I guess I'm-
- I'm not hearing you.
- Oh, sorry.
I'm interested, I guess,
in to what extent this
problematic that you've posed,
in terms of ways that Marx was unable
to think capitalism has impacted
our critical consciousness,
whether we can just approach
the archive as such,
or whether there's a particular way
in which the framing of capitalism
as the problem has actually
inhibited our critical capacity
for reflection?
- Well, I think that as I'm
listening to your question,
I'm also reminded that the series here
is the value of "Capital."
And I hope my, you know,
kind of taking Marx to task
doesn't imply that I
don't value "Capital,"
because I value it enormously.
And I think one of the
things that Marx's critique
of political economy does is help us
to take apart the otherwise
very, very opaque,
liberal, philosophical assumptions
that guide so much of Western analysis.
And so I think that's
a big part of, I think,
what we need to do in order
to sort of undo some of the assumptions
that guide how we
understand these systems.
I mean, for instance,
one of the reasons Marx's
critique is so compelling to me
and one I want to try to use
to understand colonial slavery
is because a lot of the
mainstream historiography
is very happy to figure
the Atlantic slavery system
as nothing more or less
than the continuation
of late medieval systems, you know,
already in existence.
And so there's a failure to
really reckon with the way
that colonial slavery was a
revolutionary transformation
of late medieval and earlier systems.
And I think Marx's analysis
can help us do that,
with some corrections for some
of the things, the
blinders, that Marx had.
- You have some other questions.
I wanna just throw one in, in the middle,
'cause you're on the topic.
That is that I see that you
want to eliminate this other,
really other system complete in itself
without comparing it
constantly to capital,
but it does seem since
it's the first innovation
or it's going on simultaneously
with things that are going on in Europe,
in other realms,
where you see the influences going there
from this system of bookkeeping,
this idea of surplus value
and how it might have,
even if it's speculative
I'm curious, influenced this
other invention, Europe?
- Yeah, and I'm curious too.
I mean, I think that's what we all need
to be trying to figure out.
And I think it's not gonna be something
that we're gonna figure out necessarily
through the mode of, you
know, empirical research.
I mean, I wonder what are
the structures of feeling?
What are the things that
are embedded in a culture?
And again, that's where
I think it really matters
to realize that three centuries
of realizing the capacity
to produce surplus labor
through the alienation of labor power,
how does that not set the stage
for the subsequent revolutionary shift
that Marx is so keen to track?
And again, you know, part of
what I want to make clear,
and I probably didn't in the talk,
is that I'm actually less frustrated
that Marx didn't do the things
he could and should have done
because I don't think it's
really that mysterious
that Marx wanted to sort of confine things
the way that he did.
I mean, he had some very real goals.
He really was trying to help
stoke the revolutionary shift
in his 19th century moment.
So it's less really that
I'm frustrated with Marx,
but that I'm frustrated
with Marxism, right.
For not going ahead and
asking the questions
that Marx didn't ask.
Because what's so interesting
is how much he did,
but he didn't.
And that's why I really like, you know,
Lisa's way of of showing us
how he sees but doesn't see.
So much of the analysis
that I'm looking for
is there in "Capital."
You always think he's right
about to really go there.
So again, he knows.
On some level, he does know.
I think.
- I'm with you.
All right, let's come to some
more questions in the chat.
If you don't mind, I will open,
ask to open the mic of Florie Seery.
Short but interesting question,
if you will say yours.
- [Florie] Sure. Thank you.
There are a million things
wrong with slavery obviously,
but it seems, could you
speak about how it really
in my estimation interfered with any kind
of innovation in agriculture?
- I'm sorry. Can you say that again?
- [Florie] Can you opine a bit
about how slavery interfered
with innovation in agriculture?
- Hmm.
I mean, I'm not sure I
would say that it did.
Plantation managers were always trying
to figure out new ways to make
the system more productive,
experimenting with different cultigens
of whatever the crop was
that they were making their
enslaved workers produce.
- [Florie] Was there not,
because there was such a reliance
on this free abusive labor,
did that not impede the idea
of thinking more creatively
about systems to produce
in a way that wouldn't be so harmful?
- I don't, you know, I
mean, I think it's relative.
I guess I'm hesitating,
because there's such a powerful sense,
and you get this in Marx,
I mean, he has a whole passage
about this somewhere in "Capital,"
I'm forgetting exactly where.
This notion, again,
this was such a powerful
idea in the 19th century
that slavery was inefficient.
Again, of course,
comparatively speaking, it was.
But again, I don't know that it's helpful
to evaluate the thinking
of plantation owners
relative to what was going to come
with the kinds of innovations
around productivity that
shaped industrial capitalism.
I mean, I think if you
were to ask the planters,
they understood themselves to
be people who were interested
in doing things better.
I mean, there was a whole genre
of, you know, plantation
management literature
that was about this very thing
within the limits of what was available
in terms of scientific
thought, in terms of technology
in the 16th, 17th, and 18th centuries,
particularly the 18th century
and into the early 19th century.
- One thing I was taking from your talk
and your argument is that
the strategies of management
in the slave trade system
itself were innovations.
These are technologies,
technologies of control,
of movement of human beings,
of conversion of human
beings into commodities,
which you explained so eloquently happened
going across the Atlantic.
Those are technologies, even
if they're not machines.
- Yeah, I mean things like the Dolben Act.
The Dolben Act in 1788 where they said,
well, you know what?
Yeah, we've decided that
overcrowding is causing more deaths
in the Middle Passage.
So here's how we're gonna manage it.
You know, we're gonna calculate
just how much square footage
per body makes death acceptable.
You know, gives us a quotient of mortality
that is acceptable.
That was late 18th century innovation.
- And it's a beautiful parallel.
I hate to keep saying this.
Not beautiful, but it is a
parallel to what Marx says
about wage labor which is
it's this peculiar commodity
that gets shaped and pushed around,
and the technologies of
life are intimately bound up
with the production of surplus value.
Can we go, I'm gonna pick
and choose a little bit,
'cause some of them are not,
some of the questions
are not exactly on topic,
but there is a question
of the relationship
of this system to systems of
indigenous and slave labor.
So let's ask Sebastian
Lopez to ask their question.
Thanking Audrey for finding
these names in the list
and unmuting them in this total
mess that we're living in.
Thank you, Audrey.
- [Sebastian] Hi, thank you for the talk.
It's so generative,
And I feel like there's many
different theoretical points
that I think open up perspective
on how many different formations
were happening constantly
in what we call capital at the moment.
And so I was wondering,
even though you weren't
talking about this,
but in gesturing to the
multiplicity of formations
at this moment,
if you could elaborate a little
on how you see the relation
between Atlantic slave
labor and, for example,
the different forms of slave
labor that were happening
for indigenous peoples in the Americas?
And I'm thinking, for example,
there's this particular narrative
that the encomienda was abolished
and then kind of like
indigenous labor disappeared,
but then that transmitted
into different forms
of forced labor.
And so I'm thinking of like
(speaking in foreign language)
and stuff like that.
And so the question is coming out of like,
how do we understand
the land dispossession
and slave labor and
also the different forms
in which indigenous land's
labor as well changed?
And how, yeah, kind of
like something like that.
- Yeah, yeah, no, that's a great question.
Thank you.
Well, one of the reasons
I occasionally on purpose
in the talk referred not
just to colonialism generally
but more specifically to
racial settler colonialism
was in fact to try to signify
how much the system
that we're referring to
really, really, really
should be understood,
has to be understood
as a system that used, as I always put it,
slavery and indigenous dispossession
as twin tools of colonizing.
And that's something that
I'd say is a leading edge
of new work.
I think it's a wonderful
turn that's happening
in scholarship on the early Americas
to recognize the intertwined stories
of African and indigenous slavery
and of indigenous
territorial dispossession
and colonizing and slavery that
accompanies that colonizing.
So we know so much more now
because of the research that's starting
to turn into publications
in the past 10 years or so
about how prolific indigenous slavery was
and how much, even as in
some parts of the Americas,
indigenous slavery gave way
to other systems of
exploitation like encomienda,
repartimiento,
that they are still systems
that completely disrupt indigenous systems
of rule, of dominion, of sovereignty,
and they're of a piece
with African slavery,
they're of a piece
alongside African slavery
with what colonizing entailed.
I hope that answers the
question a little bit.
- Okay, let's go to some more questions,
if everyone has energy.
We're all low energy,
because it's been such
an exhausting 24 hours.
So we'll just admit that.
But we're going to keep going
'cause this is of lasting importance.
There's some technical questions
about some Marxian categories.
- Yeah, well, what I would say to that,
and thank you for that question.
What I would say to that
is that is why I tried
to make it clear that
I'm certainly not trying
to collapse the distinction
between the two labor forms,
because they were different.
But I am insisting
that the initial one
involving colonial slavery needs
to be more squarely centered
in the story of capital
than Marx is able or willing to do.
And on the question of
social reproduction,
again, that's where the need
to really come to grips
with the scale of the slave
trade comes into play,
because that was the system's
means of social reproduction.
- [Catherine] Right, that's
what I was thinking, exactly.
- That's how it is that you,
and the only way we have to
really take the measure of it
is demographic scholarship and research,
that, I mean, I try to teach this stuff
and my students' eyes just glaze over it,
because it's dry stuff.
But it's the demographic
data is the reflection
of what does it mean to have populations
that cannot reproduce
themselves biologically?
And so every time a slave ship comes back,
you know, and that's why
it's so compelling to me
to get this planter Cary Helyar to say,
"I'm gonna make these
slaves buy more slaves."
I mean, that is the logic.
That's the system.
- I'm going to skip a little bit down
to some questions that are more on topic.
I'm not ignoring the people
with broader questions,
but I wanna focus around the talk
at least first, if that's okay.
I'm gonna read the
question for Berto Marotta
whose microphone is out.
Question is, "How would
you articulate the relation
"between the appropriation of slave labor
"and the appropriation of nature,
"the ecological nature?"
- The appropriation of what?
- Nature.
Which Berto is calling ecological surplus
in the longue duree.
Alienation of labor, alienation of nature.
- How would I characterize the
relationship between the two?
- Yeah, I'm not sure what
the question is getting at,
but let's speculate.
- Hm.
Well, it's not a question I
have given a lot of thought to.
I guess, thinking off the top of my head,
I would say that were I to pursue it,
I think it would lead me again
to taking more seriously
than I think we have in
historical scholarship
what are the logics of colonizing?
You know, what are the costs?
What are the technologies
of dispossession?
What are the environmental
consequences of plantation labor?
And there are scholarship that
is beginning to pursue this.
I'm not caught up on it to be blunt,
but I think there's a literature emerging
that correlates to the question.
- Why don't we go on?
- It's a good question.
It's a good avenue to pursue.
- Next question on the
list is from Deonte Harris.
Can we unmute Deonte?
This is a question kind of
solidly in your wheelhouse.
- [Deonte] Yes, I am here.
Thank you so much Dr.
Smallwood for this talk.
I hope that you're able to hear me okay.
- [Dr. Smallwood] Yes.
- [Deonte] The question I had was thinking
about processes of
commodification and also thinking
about labor power and wanting
to have more discussion
about the differences between
commodification of things
versus the commodification
of human beings, right.
And also how then to analyze
these relationally together
to understand that there were
multiple processes happening
at the same time, which
makes this particular system
so interesting, unique and
horrifying at the same time.
So if you could speak a bit to,
about this process of
commodifying human beings
in this Atlantic system
and how then their combined labor powers
then to I guess use
to generate or create more commodities
for the international market.
- Yeah.
The commodification of people,
that's where my research took off.
And the book that I
wrote on the slave trade.
It was when I went into the
archives of the slave trade,
I would ask myself,
"What have I learned that
I didn't already know
"about the slave trade and how it worked?"
And that literally was my method.
And it's what led to the
structure of the book,
which became a story organized
around commodification
as how people became slaves
and how the system achieved the efficiency
that it did achieve.
Within the context of the
17th and 18th centuries,
it was an efficient system, I would say.
Again, that's how it did
what it shouldn't have been able to do,
which was to displace so
many millions of people.
And so, you know, I think in
that sense, the commodification
of people really reflected a logic
that became very comfortable.
And this is how it becomes,
you know, and I'm thinking of
Cedric Robinson's work here.
This is how it becomes a
differentiating logic, right?
A logic that is without necessarily even
yet producing what we would recognize
as obvious discourses of race,
but producing certainly a logic
of some humans being more readily
and more appropriately treated
as though they are things than others.
And so it's not particularly different
than the commodification of things,
except the oddity, the peculiarity,
to return to the Marxian formulation,
of the human as a commodity
is that it's a perishable commodity.
And there are some things
that share that quality,
but that is also part of what
becomes so profoundly inhumane
in the violence of colonial slavery
is the kinds of choices
and the kinds of violence and destruction
that has to be naturalized and normalized
in order to produce people
as though they are things.
So to reduce, for instance, people
to one of four demographic categories
of either being a man or a
woman or a boy or a girl,
that kind of evacuation of
all qualities of personhood
in order to reduce a crowd
of people to a slave cargo,
so that a slave ship can
continue its scheduled movement
in transatlantic circuits.
I hope that begins to answer the question.
- [Deonte] Absolutely,
thank you so very much.
- Thanks.
I want to move to another question
by my colleague, Lisa Lowe,
Who's been invoked a
couple of times tonight.
We will give her the microphone.
Audrey, would you unmute Professor Lowe?
Thank you.
- Thank you for your beautiful talk.
I sense that your critique of
Marx has much greater stakes
than simply correcting
his analysis of capitalism
in an empirical sense,
though, I'm persuaded that his reduction
of slavery as primitive
accumulation does obscure the scale
and periodization and
the nature of violence
and the bioavailability
of the enslaved body
and the forms of extraction and so forth.
But I wanted to ask you what you think,
if you think there's a material
or political effect or afterlife
of this mistaken reduction,
the missing of slavery as labor
or surplus value circulating
within a global labor market,
and what the consequences
of periodizing slavery
as primitive accumulation
or prior to capitalism might be?
What does that say about what we can't see
about the continuation
of primitive accumulation
as co-evil or continuous with?
- Yeah, yeah.
Thank you for that question, Lisa.
Well, I think for me, the stakes are that,
and I guess I was trying to
gesture at this a little bit
in the very, the last few
sentences of the talk.
You know, I think if we were to consider
that colonial slavery is squarely
within the ambit of the history
of capital C capitalism,
it would mean not only a rethinking
of the relationship of slavery
to industrial capitalization,
but it would entail a rethinking
of slavery's relationship to our present.
I mean, I think it would allow us
to understand capitalism today
as the continued playing
out of colonial slavery.
It would allow us to see ourselves
as part of a genealogy
that begins with slavery.
It would make slavery
part of our genealogy.
And I think that that has
profound, productive implications.
- [Lisa] Thank you.
- Okay.
Yes, I was getting
on a subchannel a text
from a graduate student
which is something I wanted to add too,
which is that it really
makes the whole metaphoric
in "Capital" stand out.
This is from a graduate student.
She sent this privately,
but I'm gonna out her, Vanessa Gubbins.
Every time Marx says it's like slaves,
wage labor is slavery.
It's all there.
It's right on the surface of the text.
- Yeah, it's haunted by slavery.
- It's really haunted by slavery.
Hard to imagine he's thinking
of Rome in those instances.
Well, thank you very much
for this kind presence,
a brilliant opening up of the text,
a stand on a day that's really
very difficult for everyone.
We really appreciate your coming,
and we hope that people take
up this challenge you've given
to fill in the gaps and
make the connections
and give us a better
picture of our genealogy.
So thank you so much.
- Thank you very much for having me.
- Thank you.
This is another moment of big applause.
(claps) This would sound very loud.
Thank you.
- Thanks.